azad c'est ça moi j'ai deux mamans mais
tu le dis encore un des fois où j'aurais
des mamans baver
[Musique]
comme mon père m'a annoncé qu'il est
homosexuel
ils ne sont que j'avais 11 ans quand
on est dans la maison et que je crie
maman il ya les 2km répond nous il y en
a aucune des victimes répondre pensant
que c'est l'autre que j'appelle ils sont
nés d'une précédente union
hétérosexuelle où ils ont été adoptés
[Musique]
parfois leurs parents les ont conçus
grâce à un don de sperme anonyme ou par
mère porteuse
on sait que le premier problème avec nos
enfants on va nous tomber dessus en bon
voilà on y est pas de maman voilà ce que
vous avez fait c'est
en france selon les associations cent à
trois cent mille enfants aurait au moins
un parent homosexuel
[Musique]
qu'ils vivent en ville en banlieue ou à
la campagne ce que nous avons rencontré
vont plutôt bien
ils ont entre 3 et 45 ans leurs parents
sont profs stuart ou militaires
l'image que les gens du collège avait
des homosexuels étaient négatives la
fofolle agréable dans les fesses etc je
pense que je pourrais tomber amoureuse
d'un garçon ou d'une fille met vraiment
en fonction de la personnalité on sent
bien moi même par nous tous les autres
me sens pas différent
[Musique]
comment se construit style et comment
font-ils face au regard des autres
enfants ados adultes leurs parents sont
homos et ils ont accepté de témoigner
sans faux semblant
[Musique]
bougez plus
normal normal dans la famille d'azhar
trois ans et demi il n'y a pas de papa
mais il ya deux mamans
marjolaine 40 ans et alice 29 ans
pour concevoir leur fille les deux
jeunes mères ont eu recours à un don de
sperme anonyme
pour cela elles se sont rendus en
belgique pays où contrairement à la
france l'insémination artificielle est
autorisé aux couples de femmes
parce qu'elle est la plus âgée des deux
c'est marjolaine qui a porté hasard
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui elle attend une
petite soeur conçu de la même manière
[Musique]
tu te trouves comment
est ce que tu as déjà demandé à des
mamans commenté tv au monde
se souvient plus
venu au monde ça veut dire une lettre
comment tu es comment tu as été
fabriqués
alors m'a déjà on avait très envie
d'avoir un bébé un enfant alors comme tu
sais deux femmes ça ne peut pas avoir un
enfant toutes les deux on est allé dans
une clinique pour demander des graines
de monsieur pour pouvoir remettre la
graine de monsieur avec une graine de
femmes en l'occurrence damien et ça ça
se mélange avec une graine de maman
marjolaine et sa fabrique et un bébé qui
a grandit grandit grandit jusqu'au mont
- il est sorti du ventre
et on l'a appelée attend
les premières questions très petit dès
qu'elle a su parler c'était
vrai papa
mais c'était une question vraiment de
curiosité enfin pas une question
angoissée n'ai rien c'était aussi voyant
les autres familles
ben moi est ce que j'ai un papa est donc
la réponse était non méthodes non t'as
pas de papa n'y a pas de papa dans ta
famille la question est venue comme ça
sous une forme
sous une forme de l'affirmation un peu
provocatrice mais sûrement pour voir
aussi si ça me mettait en difficulté
si j'étais capable de répondre et s'il
fallait s'angoisser ou pas on se poser
plein de questions évidemment avoir la
conception est ce qu'on fait le bon
choix est ce que ce sera compliqué pour
elle
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment avoir un papa
et une maman dans une famille plein de
questions comme ça et puis on s'est dit
que avoir deux parents c'est c'est très
enrichissant de toute façon et que et
que voilà on peut pas tout contrôler que
un enfant c'est aussi un être fort 1 à
32 venir qui sera puisée là où on en a
besoin les ressources donc voilà
[Musique]
m
et pour rassurer s'il en était besoin
alice et marjolaine voici théo 19 ans et
clément 26 ans
eux aussi ont de mer et pas de père
c'est isabelle qui a porté les deux
garçons
marie-pierre elle a porté les néo
etienne 27 ans absent pendant le
tournage pour cause de vacances
tout comme la petite hasard les trois
frères sont eux aussi né grâce à une
insémination artificielle avec don de
sperme anonyme
dans le jargon on dit paris à d un
acronyme un peu barbare même pour ceux
qui sont concernés est-ce que vous avez
déjà questionné vos mères sur vous
comment vous aviez été conçue très très
jeune je crois que j'avais 5 ans
c'est moi qui vous avez posé la question
et vous maniez moi je vais me souvenir
que vous nous aviez répondu
on m'explique ans j'avais été conçu par
ivg
pas ce qui se passe dans tes amis
mais non mais
faria
ressemble à 40 cents
voilà ce à quoi je parle ou alors tu te
disais un enfant si je veux quand je
veux voilà c'est ça pendant des années
de quoi un des slogans des femmes dans
les années 68 70 cela c'était un enfant
si je veux quand je veux mais c'était
par rapport à l'avortement est en fait à
l'époque où nous on voulait des enfants
c'était un peu le même slogan d'une
certaine façon c'était un enfant si je
veux quand je veux mais dans le sens
dans le sens inverse c'est à dire que
voilà
même si je même si je suis pas dans un
couple hétérosexuel et voilà qu'est ce
que tu as compris à cinq ans bah j'avais
compris que c'était quelqu'un donc qui
avait donné son sperme et que c'est
comme ça j'avais été conçu
donc j'avais compris le principe et pour
moi ça m'a n'est pas quand mais parler
des petites graines
mais vous n'avez pas parler des choses
par leur nom
mais je me souviens qu'à une certaine
période ou si on leur a expliqué je sais
plus haut qu'elle vaut 3 que par contre
il fallait essayer de
être vigilant sur à qui il le disait par
rapport à ce que ça pouvait déclencher
comme réaction est que c'était quand
même qu'ils aient bien conscience que
que c'était pas ordinaire et que ça
pouvait surprendre et déstabiliser des
personnes et qu'ils se protègent de sa
ne pas connaître la moitié de son
patrimoine génétique par exemple tu t'es
jamais dit j'aimerais bien savoir à quoi
il ressemble ou à six chiffres question
j'ai fait bon ben je ressemble vachement
quand même à isabelle est ce que mon
père commence à devenir chaud
puisque c'est ce que le service et parme
et
[Rires]
effectivement mais tel quel qui
effectivement quelles caractéristiques
physiques
gsk il me ressemble ça mais après le
connaître non
si je reviens régulièrement pour dire
mais où parce que je croyais que j'avais
un père au long des jeux pas quoi et
puis en fait dans quel pays vous êtes
allé pour qui et tout ça ça c'est
l'interrogation qui revient
régulièrement parce que j'oublie au
forum est
donc ça a été conçu en france à magny à
paris et moi c'était à montpellier
c'est un scoop tiens le chien du cim
génération parisienne on sait pas d'où
étaient les donneurs oui c'est sûr c'est
la conception c'est l'âge où on peut
vous dire la
mieux mais pas pas de lieu où s'est
passé l'acte mais
l'homme qui avait donné son sperme qu'on
sait pas c'est pas lui de lui venait on
aurait pu être moi oui non non non je
sais en tout cas pour toi c'est elle
m'avait demandé il agit ni qu elle
voulait quelques couleurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
jules et théo ont quatre ans et demi ces
petits jumeaux connaissent eux déjà tous
deux leur origine génétique
et pourtant dans leur famille il n'y a
pas de maman leurs deux papas karine 48
ans et yann 47 ans ont fait appel à une
mère porteuse à l'étranger une pratique
illégale en france j'ai un petit sourire
je le dis si tu regarde pas ça va durer
longtemps
attendu de tous alors un on ne tripote
pas tout ce qu'il ya sur l'heureux papa
déjà voilà ça commence
c'est qui ça
ok ce qu'elle a fait pour vous même en
gala
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
eh bien vous apporter dans
[Musique]
vous étiez dans son ventre
et donc la n va et nous a aidés à faire
notre famille
parce que tu sais bien que deux papas ça
peut pas faire des bébés 1 il faut une
maman pour faire un bébé tout ça c'est
les aider de te regarde c'est papa karim
avec un petit peu les baby blacks dans
le ventre des dans le ventre de papa
non voilà dans le ventre des mamans
c'est quelqu'un envers qui on est
éternellement reconnaissants et on est
toujours en contact
on l'a au téléphone régulièrement par
mail on l'a on lui envoie des photos
d'eux
des enfants qui grandissent
et nous on en voit aussi de sa famille
et puis on espère la rolls la revoir
tout bientôt l'a pas eue qu'on n'a pas
revus là encore c'est important pour
vous que les enfants regardent
maintenant parce que c'est une partie de
leur vie donc après on serait dans le
cas de
deux jambes des filles qui font appel à
lui à d pour avoir des enfants avec de
nouveaux inconnus bon on n'a pas le
choix mais là elle existe
pourquoi la faire disparaître nous elle
le prend la place de personne
voilà c'est le même jour elle qui a
porté les enfants donc non non c'est
précieux on voulait aussi avoir une
maman identifiés pour les protéger c'est
à dire qu' il ait la possibilité à
l'école de dire oui on a deux papas mais
on a une maman on n'est pas complètement
différent des autres
après on s'aperçoit au jour
d'aujourd'hui qu'ils en font quelque
chose de différent que ce à quoi on
s'attendait puisque régulièrement ils
répondent qu'ils n'ont pas de maman
[Musique]
c'est bien mais c'est très bien
ouais
ben dis donc t'es trop fort
[Musique]
oh
et pourtant avant de fonder leur famille
karim et yann se sont longtemps posé la
question d'élever des enfants sont
qu'une mère soit présente
[Musique]
voilà alors pour confronter les
expériences et pour que leurs enfants
voient d'autres familles comme la leur
ils invitent régulièrement des amis paix
reggae comme
lionel et fabien ont adopté leur petit
linth à l'âge de 3 ans en haïti
l'enfant a donc connu sa mère biologique
et vécu avec elle les premiers mois de
sa vie
[Musique]
nice il m'a identifié à
la représentation d'une mère qui pouvait
avoir et même dans l'intimité strictes
il m'a appelé pendant une courte période
maman et moi je les sais pas ce que ce
mot là il faut pas que ce soit un mot
interdit à mouvaux pesant je les écris
mais maintenant une audi quasiment plus
jamais même le soir ou autres et alors
d'aujourd'hui dans le fonctionnement de
tous les jours je me rends compte que
notre enfant de recherche nullement se
référant là que se référant féminin il a
trouvé en où il a trouvé en dans ses
parents je suis convaincu et
heureusement qu'un homme peut avoir ce
rôle maternel peut avoir ce maternage et
peut remplacer une mère on peut être
homme est entre guillemets au niveau
interne a effectivement en tant
qu'homosexuel je pense qu'on a cassé des
carcans et qu'on laisse s'exprimer une
part féminine que beaucoup des terreaux
on est qu'il laisse aussi maintenant
s'exprimer mais pour moi la référence
féminine avec une poitrine des cheveux
longs formats et des fameux blattes et
jeu court mais je veux dire la référence
féminine ils vont elles et la pioche et
en dehors en dehors parce qu'il ya des
tatas des mamies des nounous des tati
des copines des machins il y en a
partout
et la référence féminine avec poitrine
et cheveux longs numéro 1 de jules et de
théo ces ora la mère de karim lanthier
maman
c'est m'a fait un bisou
tout le monde a eu le bisou calais on
rentre on va manger des crêpes
saura comment est ce que vous avez réagi
quand karim et yann
ont annoncé qu'ils allaient devenir père
je vais très très bien réagi c'était
vraiment l'espoir de ma vie
que je pensais que ça n'arriverait plus
parce que j'ai perdu mon fils est né il
ya dix huit ans de ça
étant donné qu'il est mort ils pouvaient
pas il nous a pas laissés d'enfants il
n'était pas marié rien donc voilà on
s'est retrouvé avec notre chagrin et
karim est homosexuel visez ben voilà à
partir de maintenant
on finira tous seuls
dans notre coin c'était triste quoi pour
moi c'était important de devenir grand
mère ah oui bien sûr oula bien sûr si
vous saviez la joie qui nous ont
rapporté ces deux petits c'est moi ils
ont rempli ma vie voilà à baby et est
évident après ça et quand j'ai eu théo
et chul s'était
jamais les larmes aux yeux
tu veux goûter lequel qu'est-ce que tu
regardes tu as des crèves tu vas les
souvenirs la fleur d'oranger
aura une mamie gâteau qui prend son rôle
de grand-mère très à coeur et qui assure
ainsi au quotidien ce fameux rôle de
référent féminin auprès de jules et de
théo
les gens qui estiment que dans les
familles homoparentales ont peu manqué
de présence féminine
peut-être doivent penser qu'on vit dans
une île déserte entouré d'homosexuels
garçons mais ça n'existe pas ça donc
voilà je livre plein de trucs avec leurs
mamies sont toujours collés c'est la
présence féminine c'est la grande
[Rires]
[Musique]
et quand on est trois garçons comme
étienne 27 ans le frère aîné absent
pendant le tournage théo 19 ans et
clément 26 ans qu'on a été élevé par
deux mers comment trouve-t-on son modèle
masculin
[Musique]
de papa de guerre bah non pas
par et sam ont en tout cas ça que je
m'en rappelle je crois que j'en avais
discuté avec étienne parce que je sais
c'est que toi tu es au en fait appris
entre guillemets le modèle détiennent
ouais le modèle le modèle mais la figure
paternelle la figure paternelle suis pas
l'image d'homme ce pas vraiment figure
paternelle presque paternel
c'est vraiment l'image du père quoi
c'est en fait c'est plat et puisqu'ils
sont d'une image une image d'homme en
fait pour construire son identité
céline
salut touche poser mes questions
[Musique]
existentielles non mais un peu voilà
voilà ces questions que tu te poses u2
voilà bah c'est plus à lui que je les ai
posé c'est vrai d'autres mais
c'est vrai que moi ça marrant c'est une
question que je me suis toujours posé
c'est moi j'ai lu etienne j'ai eu toi
voilà j'ai eu des exemples entre
guillemets
mais toi enfin chaleur enfin pour éviter
ces gens moi j'ai eu etienne
effectivement c'est etienne
7e qui bat je pense qu'il a fait figure
d'homme et puis c'est à lui que je
posais toutes les questions que je me
posais ça mais c'est vrai qu'il était
vachement plus mal de la
faible différence d'âge mais il était
beaucoup plus mature que moi c'était pas
plus il traînait avec vraiment beaucoup
de mais qu'en fait qu'ils étaient
une dizaine voire imminente une
vingtaine d'années plus que lui et je
pense que c'est effectivement ça c'est
plutôt il ya beaucoup parlé avec ces
mecs là
il ya toujours
il a toujours voulu que tout le monde se
sente bien et c
comme lui parce que lui s'était toujours
senti très bien et je crois qu'il ya un
mois senti un peu comme ça comme un
protecteur en frère protecteur
l'image qu'on m'a du frère coentraîneur
autre génération autre histoire
caroline cécile 45 ans célibataire et
sans enfant a elle en revanche eu un
père
mais à l'âge de deux ans sa mère evelyne
a divorcé pour vivre avec dany une
histoire d'amour entre femmes qui a duré
quarante ans et qui a fait scandale
caroline cécile a attendu quarante deux
ans avant d'évoquer dans un livre tous
les quolibets et même les insultes dont
elle a été victime plus jeunes parce
qu'elles étaient élevés par deux femmes
lesbiennes
les adultes s'adresser à moi pour vous
mire ce qu'ils avaient en travers de la
gorge par rapport à cette vie de couple
de femmes
donc c'est cette rancune cette animosité
l'a vomi c'est
là il me l'a jeté comme ça à travers la
figure comme si j'étais moi la
responsable de ce
ce couple de femmes a par exemple
rejoint maquis je suis adolescente je
vais sortir avec des amis et puis j'ai
ma grand mère qui est là et puis elle me
regarde me maquiller
mais pas un peu trop et en fait je
m'aperçois que
elle fait référence à à maman est en
fait là elle me dit
tu vas pas devenir une traînée comme ta
mère
pourquoi te reprocher de maquiller alors
que savait très bien que je me
maquillais pas parce qu'à travers le
maquillage je devenais une femme et
quelle femme que j'allais devenir quel
chemin j'allais prendre celui dépravé de
toit ou celui
raisonnable et rangée de ce qu'elle
pouvait avoir
oui parce que pour ma mère dont pour moi
et pour toi et pour beaucoup de gens on
est des dépravés dans le livre de ma
fille j'ai découverte tout ce qu elle ne
m'avait pas dire tout ce qu elle ne nous
avait pas dit pour nous protéger toutes
ces saloperies qu'on lui disait pourquoi
elle parce qu'on n'avait pas le courage
de nous dire à nous et pourquoi ce
faisant les protéger ben parce que en
fait on s'aperçoit qu'elles ont déjà
leur souffrance elles ont dix ont déjà
beaucoup de choses au niveau
professionnel aux eyzies au niveau
amical familial que j'ai assisté à des
cette violente
à des scènes quand maman est allée
prévenir ses reins expliqué à ses
parents qu'elle allait vivre avec une
femme
ça a été les cats ont quoi là il ya une
violence physique son père l'a frappé sa
mère l'insulté en fait elle s'est
retrouvée propulsée contre le mur et
puis là le gifler battu par son père
elle s'est écroulée la saignée moi
j'étais dans les mains de ma grand mère
j'ai hurlé pour moi ça y est l'été
mortain
[Musique]
quarante ans plus tard la relation entre
les trois générations de femmes s'est
apaisée
madeleine la grand mère vit aujourd'hui
dans une maison de retraite
evelyne et caroline cécile viennent
régulièrement lui rendre visite
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui encore l'homosexualité
d'evelyne reste un sujet sensible
est ce que vous vous souvenez quand vous
avez compris que votre fille dit forcé
pour vivre avec une femme est ce vous
souvenez je m'en souviens je n'ai pas
compris je n'ai pas aimé surtout
je n'ai pas aimé mais je n'ai pas
compris je n'ai pas aimé
vous aviez peur du regard des autres oui
mais j'avais peur de rome deux jours est
ce que vous avez eu peur pour votre
petite fille et ben oui
j'avais peur j'avais peur que
cela perturbe le sol une petite vie
c'est à dire
bonjour
je suis pas comme un m'expliquer
maintenant
vous en avez discuté car lille cécile
avec votre grand mère d' de ça déjà
non
parce que c'était peut-être certainement
trop dur pour elle d'en parler et pour
moi je savais que ça pouvait provoquer
des choses dramatiques puis remuer les
sentiments difficile quoi manier oui on
tue pour moi que m sort du vent du sud
et en même temps ça n'a pas eu d'impact
négatif non si tu fais le recul le même
blog me plaît bien
a eu plus de peur que de mal finalement
oui sûrement
[Musique]
et si le sujet a longtemps été tabou
dans la famille de caroline ses fils
dans celle de marie 10 ans et et
mathilde de 12 ans
l'homosexualité de leur mère a très vite
été un sujet de discussion totalement
décomplexée
[Musique]
elle aussi était petit 2 et 4 ans quand
marisa leur mère a quitté jean-luc leur
père pour une femme
aujourd'hui c'est avec leur maman et
ludivine sa nouvelle compagne que les
deux soeurs habitent
le week end elles sont avec leur père
strauss tout
j'avais le choix entre trois films alors
y'a lost and delirious celui que toi tu
as déjà vu mais je crois que matt hill
l'a pas vu il ya un fucking amal tu te
rappelles de ce que c'est comme
l'histoire c'est les deux ludo
collégienne et puis gazon maudit bon la
pluie a pas bien longtemps mais lisa
c'est quoi l'idée là je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait énormément de films et
héros à la télévision et que
malheureusement ils passaient pas assez
de films sur les histoires d'amour
homosexuelle et je me suis dit que je
voyais pas pourquoi je serais obligé de
montrer que défilent les terreaux à mes
enfants
en fait c'est l'histoire de deux jeunes
filles qui sont en pension et qui sont
très amoureuse et il y en a une qui
s'assume complètement et l'autre à
d'énormes problèmes avec sa famille et
puis de ce fait elle va être obligée
d'arrêter leurs relations à cause de la
famille
voilà
c'est toi la dernière fois qu'ils me
posais une question quand on était dans
la pharmacie que deux femmes s'en fait
pas l'amour
ne sera pas tu vois poteau plaisir parce
qu'on s'aime très fort
j'ai souvent eu des mamans qui ne voient
revenir oui mais tu es en train de
bourrer la tête de tes enfants parce que
tu te rends pas compte
tu es lesbienne donc de ce fait a envie
d'avoir des filles deviennent mais moi
je m'en fous de 2,2 key2key elles vont
aimer demain ou ce qu'elles seront
demain partir du moment où elles sont
heureuses donc comme je l'aurais très
bien dit je leur ai dit mais en gros
vous vous regardez simplement les
émissions vous pouvez faire passer
regardez simplement les films que vos
enfants regardent et dites-moi qui c'est
qui pourtant la tête de l'enfant
les parents et les parents izarry mais
convergentes quelque part leur gamin en
leur montrant toujours la même chose
n'est-ce pas le choix ne serait ce que
pour déjà les contes de fées mais j'ai
hyper galères et quand mes gamines avait
trois quatre ans pour leur trouver des
débouchés sur sur les histoires d'amour
entre deux fils par exemple princesse et
une crèche et une princesse voilà où un
prince qui a cherché un prince eh ben ça
c'est très dur tu te rappelles jetons
avait acheté 1 quand tu étais petit mais
non en tant que mère lesbienne je n'ai
pas l'impression de bourg et la tête de
mes enfants en leur montrant des films
lesbiens et oui je pars du principe
qu'il faut plus leur a montré qu'on soit
hétéro ou peu importe la sexualité qu'on
peut avoir il faut montrer
déjà cités les rejoint la plaine film
différent à nos gosses pour que eux ils
se sentent pas prisonnier et qu'ils
aient pas l'impression d'être anormal
non bloqué dans une situation qui n'est
pas la leur en fait donc permettre
d'avoir un panel de choix sans leur dire
il faut que tu sois comme ci ou comme ça
et alors qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
les filles de ce film est ému et mouche
très ému
est ce que ça te met en colère est ce
que ça te je trouve ça juste
injuste que les autres bay trouve ça
pas normal
toi tu pourrais tomber amoureuse d'un
garçon ou d'une fille
importe je
tombe amoureuse tu as déjà tombée
amoureuse mais c'était une fille et un
garçon plus une fille
c'est sur un terrain pareil portes salle
fonds partiellement été heureuse
hectares ont tué mais que tu veux c'est
l'essence écoute
et toi tu préfère les garçons et les
filles passais pas must devants dans ce
cas cette année j'ai eu un garçon
est ce que vous vous souvenez les fils
quand votre maman vous a expliqué
également leurs cadres est une femme en
fait elle était venue on était chez papa
ont été plus juste en dehors je devais
avoir 4 5 ans et
illumine notre fille
moi ça m'a pas choqué
ont tous rejeté toute l'italie
ça sorte
donc je pense que mathieu dans le fait
ce qui ce qui se passe là c'est que
c'est plus le fasse et pas le fait que
je sois parti avec une forme ou quoi que
ce soit qui puisse la chambouler c'est
vraiment la séparation d'avec son père
puisque c'est vrai qu'on était un couple
très très lié nous sommes toujours de
toute façon on sait on sait très bien
que les enfants vont avoir du mal ou
sont dans n'importe quelle séparation
ç'aurait été la même chose je serais
parti pour un gars sort est exactement
la même chose on a souffert pareil mais
je ne fais pas partie de ces femmes là
qui préfèrent rester à la maison avec
leurs maris avec leurs enfants et puis
jouer à au couple parfaitement de
katmandou alors qu'ils le sont
absolument pas et j'ai préféré prendre
ma vie en main et je me suis dit si
chaleureuse pesant mes gamines le sont
aussi parfois foi ou pas tu es heureuse
de la roche posay
oui tu es heureuse oui bon ça va j'ai
rien dit
[Musique]
segal évoqué avec papa
ben ouais le dimanche après un rush et
notre bonheur enfin pas tout le temps
parce que joue pas les louper mais la
plupart du temps aussi
le dur tu te rappelles pourquoi tu as
pleuré
je suis passé tout chambouler dans ma
tête la question où la séparation je
suppose que si
je dois être
je sais pas du tout ce que c'était en
tout cas ça fait quelque chose en toi
quand on en parle oui
autour de vous vous avez beaucoup de
copines qui sont dans la même situation
vous avec des parents si pages jaunes
des parents séparés et des parents et
des mamans qui vivent avec d'autres
femmes je sais pas j'ai boudé mais il ya
beaucoup de dans mon collège ya beaucoup
de personnes qui lui sont ses parents et
leurs parents ils sont séparés mais
après j'ai pas demandé si c'était avec
une femme une femme ma main
et ça ne soulagerait pas de savoir que
tu as d'autres copains copines dans la
même situation familiale que la team
ainsi un peu mire
l'association pas grand chose ça change
pas grand chose parce que il ya
on m'a jamais fait des réflexions par
rapport à ça
et à la minute après c'est pas très
important si toi entre toi et toi
comment tu te sens oui mais je me sens
bien moi même pas tous les autres ne
sent pas différente
jeudi elle fait le coup du passé
jean-luc comment vous les voyez grandir
vos filles très vite très vite elles
sont très épanouie 13 mois de moi je
suis plus à mon gamin je suis plus
internet tout ça ça marche
cette attentifs à leur évolution
fait pas trop pour moi qu'ils soient
bien
que genre scolarité marche bien
c'est un peu l'essentiel
après qu'ils aient c'est vrai que l'on
commet diraison de maintenant on va dire
où je pense pas que ça ça change quelque
chose chez elle aujourd'hui on sent que
vous assumez très bien le fait que la
maman défi soit parti pour une femme
mais est-ce que ça a toujours été le cas
au début c'est vrai qu'on n'imaginait
pas
j'imaginais pas de filles et les maisons
les enfants quoi pour quelles raisons
qu'est-ce que je connaissais pas je
connaissais pas le moment de lâcher
dans votre couple
et qu'est ce que vous avez pensé pour
vos enfants à ce moment là que si vous
êtes dit
plus pour l'éducation j'avais un peu
peur comment ça va se passer c'est à
dire je les voyais au de faire c'est
vrai qu'au début j'imaginais bas à
quelques suivre le chemin de leur mère
croit qu'elle est
bon finalement baissé
c'est pas parce qu'elle a sa mère et
lesbiennes qu'elle se voir un chemin
après ce sera leur chemin ils font ce
qu'elles veulent
[Musique]
c'était peut-être mon blog plus grosse
parce que j'avais pas papa
alors les enfants domo gay ou hétéro
c'est la grande question et les idées
reçues ne manque pas une question qu'on
a posés antoine 20 ans et à edith 25 ans
leur père jacques aujourd'hui en couple
avec patrick leur a annoncé qu'il était
homosexuel
un an après s'être séparés de leur mère
[Musique]
à l'époque est dit avec 15 ans antoine
pour mon père va annoncer qu'il était
cette fois je redonne envie cadre de
chez de chez la mère
je suis allée comme tous les dimanches
soirs à jouer à l'ordinateur
et donc je commence à jouer un truc et
puis mon père arrive s'assoit à côté de
moi a dit que mon fils est un truc à
dire quels mots exactement il a utilisé
je me souviens plus mais il m'a annoncé
donc qui préférait les hommes ou femmes
ou qu'il aimait les hommes où je sais
plus quel milan prix et je me souviens
très bien de ce moment et puis moi j'ai
réagi dans mon souvenir d'une manière
assez
détachez naturel j'ai fait à mon pauvre
tu fais ce que tu veux ça me dérange pas
trop près ce jeudi ce à quoi et voilà
est en apparence j'ai vraiment voulu
donner l'image du mec qui voit là ça ne
dérange pas je suis un mec ouvert alors
que j'avais 15 ans mais bon au fond ça
va avec un plus touchés que que ce que
je voulais au revoir et
donc voila mais je n'ai pas mal pris je
pas fait un gros bad dessus
en effet tu avais 11 entêté à
l'ordinateur tu rentrais d'un week-end
chez ta mère et je t'ai dit que voilà
patrick que tu vois souvent la maison le
patrick de l'époque c'était mon amoureux
et il m'a dit je veux pas longtemps que
je parle en tant que je pas longtemps je
te jure que tu m'as dix autres comme
savait mais pas aussi violent bon non
mais un peu tu vois je pas longtemps de
ne pas le savoir bon je suis parti je
suis sorti de la chambre
j'essaie quelques instants et après
c'est toi qui a bondi vers moi et qui a
posé un million de questions m alors
j'ai eu mais tu vas voir le sida
d'entrer au mont houy mais il va habiter
avec nous c'était plus des affirmations
de les questions mais il va habiter avec
nous ouais c'est bien il va habiter avec
nous est ce que je peux le dire à mes
copains enfin il a fallu de calmer en
disant être
pas des jeux un truc de fou très bientôt
il voulait dit moi partons je me suis
mise à pleurer et en fait je pendant le
temps de se demander pourquoi parce que
j'étais pas vrai j'étais pas choqué non
plus où j'étais même pas surprise je ne
sais pas comment dire ça et mais
rétrospectivement
retravaillant un peu dessus je crois que
c'est à cause de l'émotion mon père
parce que c'était quelque chose
d'important pour lui que je voyais bien
que ça
point que je sais pas il y avait un bon
jeu mais je n'aurais pas pu mettre de
mots à ce moment là mais je pense que
c'est pour ça que moi ça m'a secoué ça
n'a vraiment rien changé pour vous
peut-être pas le soir même mais
peut-être quelques soirs plus tard mais
vraiment
on va longtemps après et bien dans mon
livre là donc je suis à une bouchée et
puis j'ai repensé je fais pas mon père
il est gay et puis voilà ça m'a fait
bizarre fin j'ai senti des trucs chelous
en moi et jour au lendemain quand j'ai
appris quand mon père m'a annoncé qu'il
est homosexuel j'ai arrêté d'insulter
les gens de télé tout de suite et je
n'ai plus jamais dit après
antoine avait 11 ans et un garçon qui va
bientôt rentrer dans l'adolescence
connaître ses premières histoires
d'amour que vous avez eu des questions
par rapport à l'image paternelle que
vous pouviez lui renvoyer à ce moment là
j'ai pensé
qu'il était plus important qu'il le ça
justement pendant qu'il était prêt à dos
avant d'être ado voilà pour pouvoir
peut-être le gérer un peu plus un peu
plus facilement parce qu'on sait que les
ados vont ils y aller franchement
et donc je voulais pas que ces histoires
de d'affectif interviennent trop tard il
fallait que les choses soient claires
avant et puis avec ce soit complètement
dissociés qui est pas de mélange entre
la vie affective du père et puis le fait
d'être un père koala
oui j'ai bien dû quelque part imaginez
aussi
en tant que garçon il fallait qu'il ait
une image absolument de son père
hétéronormée mais bon
c'était pas le cas et c'était pas la
peine de faire croire à des choses qui
n'existaient pas ne pas faire semblant
ne pas raconter d'histoires c'est comme
ça bah oui ton perrier avec un garçon
bah oui avec un homme points
je suis pas basé sur mon père pour
construire ma vie affectueux
où j'ai pas de problème je sais très
bien je suis pas difficultés à trouver
quelqu'un
pas trop souvent faim je suis
relativement respectueux de la personne
donc voilà enfin non j'ai pas trop blême
avec mal effectué huit façons que choix
si
mon moi j'ai apparemment je suis hétéro
j'ai jamais encore ressenti
jamais encore une envie homosexuels on
peut dire qu'on verra peut-être avec le
temps ça voilà je me dis pas que c'est
impossible je me dis pas si je le suis
je vais faire un gros bad dont je
verrais bien puisque le sujet le super
bowl stop et vous ai dit le fait d'avoir
un papa homosexuel est ce que ça a eu
des répercussions sur votre vie
affective au début pas
je continue à sortir avec des garçons
comme quoi enfin au lycée quoi on est un
peu comme tout le monde comme c'est bon
c'est pas pour être comme tout le monde
je pense après je me suis dit que ça
dépendait pas de la du sexe de la
personne mais de la personne moi je
pense que je pourrais tomber amoureuse
d'un garçon ou d'une fille met vraiment
en fonction de la personnalité qui a des
garçons j'aime pas du tout aidé fille
que j'aime pas du tout est inversé mais
pour l'instant je suis jamais encore
tombé amoureux utilise juste des petites
histoires comme ça mais vraiment pas
alors que par contre j'ai vu des vraies
histoires avec des garçons et même en ce
moment
ça veut dire un flirt en soirée enfin
rien de sérieux juste pour savoir que
physiquement ça pourrait marcher quoi
mais
mais encore jamais rien de sérieux mais
après ouais je me dis vraiment que c'est
une sorte de personnalités moi je me dis
ça aussi c'est pas bête je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit mais moi j'ai jamais
rencontré une personnalité de garçons
qui m'intéresse à ce point là
mais 5 s'intéresse ans qui dit je suis
d'accord
même génération et même ouverture
d'esprit michele et fils d'isabelle et
marie pierre clément et théo
[Musique]
c'est votre affaire les filles mais
effectivement ça m'aurait pas choqué je
pense que j'aurais eu moins de mal à
assumer ma sexualité
si jamais j'étais gay mais moi je suis
avec les a mais je serais tombé sur un
homme qui me plaît qui me plaisait
particulièrement et même encore
actuellement je pense que
c'est par ailleurs là et non mais je
rencontre un homme voilà enfin je veux
dire ben
justement moi je suis enfin c'est pas
pour moi c'est pas parce qu'au final
c'est ni physique c'est que de
l'apparence et que là on est créé pour
moi ça a plus aucune enfin ça n'a pas
d'importance
oui mais j'étais bourg
le 10 francs moisins
ces traîtres
non mais oui effectivement mince voire
adolescence tard à nice
mais
oui j'ai eu une expérience en eau
lors d'une soirée istres
oui c'était aussi pendant une fête mais
je me suis très vite rendu compte qu'en
fait il n'y avait pas que moi et
pourtant je suis le seul enfant non loin
dans tous les gens que je connais donc
en fait je me dis que c'est juste
presque un stade où beaucoup de nos
expériences en face et beaucoup font
peut-être effectivement enfin c'est plus
sait plus comment dire
répandu en fait actuellement moutien
gens posent des questions est-ce que je
suis
une star de tester
les fermes homosexuels
forbo sexuelle
c'est l'époque où été catégorisés parle
ou ms je crois dans
4 les maladies mentales en fait
effectivement à cette époque là il
soutenu
que si de parent homosexuel adoptée
2000 jours à des enfants deviendrait
automatiquement de ce fait parce que
c'est une maladie transmissible de
rétractation
eh ouais
apparemment on a parlé on n'a pas chanté
le jem
l'homosexualité une maladie
transmissible un préjugé tenace dont
caroline cécile 45 ans élevés par deux
femmes a longtemps fait les frais dans
sa vie amoureuse
c'est à auxerre petite ville bourgeoise
de province où tout le monde se
connaissait que caroline cécile a grandi
témoin de ses désillusions amoureuses
anne-claire sa meilleure amie et sa
seule confidente à l'époque
jamais ces garçons quittent qui
découvrait
au fur et à mesure de notre dos toilé
lisons quoi que en fait evelyne et dany
dany n'était pas ma tante may était bien
la femme qui vivait avec maman et du
coup là c'était le choc et puis c'était
la rupture est ma première rupture
amoureuse c'était ça c'est théo alors
c'était un petit flirt c'était bon sens
en conséquence et en fait ça a eu de
grandes conséquences affective parce que
du coup quand il m'a dit mais moi je
veux pas je vois pas sortir avec une win
et ben je prenais ça en pleine poire
avec le recul je me dis que certains
d'entre eux se faisait peut-être
violence pour se séparer de caroline
parce qu'il y avait aussi la peur du
qu'en dira-t-on ils avaient peur de la
réaction de leurs parents parce que
fréquentant quelqu'un dont on ne savait
pas trop s'il était homosexuel ou pas
c'était quand même bizarre et puis la
peur des vis-à-vis des copains parce que
vis-à-vis des copains sais où tu
fréquentes cette fille tu sais les
bizarres ces mères sont homos
tu vois c'est pas très sain je me disais
voilà j'ai encore des barrières sur sur
mon chemin et ça ça me suivre mais ça me
suivra jusqu'à quand finalement parce
que c'est pas moi qui ai sur meu
sexuelle mais on ne colle et toujours
cette image cette étiquette
pour caroline cécile comme souvent chez
les enfants de haut ce n'est pas
l'orientation sexuelle de ses parents
qui a posé problème mais le regard des
autres c'est au collège qu'elle en a le
plus souffert
du froid quand même facile il avait il
avait tout pour mon me mais malmené me
maltraiter parce que en fait on vieillit
pas donc plus dans l'ombre evelyne et
daniel se cachait pas
je crois que c'était quand même courage
c'est vrai que très souvent on a croisé
des gens qui pouvaient avoir des mots
violents
il était agressif comme tous les ados il
faisait des jeux de mots sur sur son nom
de famille le fait qu'elle s'appelle
schoendoerffer ça se transformer en
chêne de faire bien sûr cet assaut
souhaite associer à lesbiennes [ __ ]
regarde les ces deux là elles sont bien
toutes les deux ensemble enfin j'aimais
pas qu'on insulte
familiale parce que c'était le nom de
papa et j'aimais pas qu'on insulte papa
ça c'était quelque chose que je
détestais
il y avait ces moments où j'ai été
agressé verbalement et où j'étais aussi
agressé physiquement j'ai eu des
agressions physiques en fait il ya deux
trois garçons qui m'ont coincé dans les
wc pour
me tripoter et puis pour me toucher
physiquement les parties génitales les
saints enfin tout ce qu'il fait comme
qu'on est une femme et donc moi j'ai
crié j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur j'ai eu
peur parce que j'étais jeune j'avais
14 15 ans et là j'ai pleuré j'ai été
pris par les professeurs donc les pions
sont arrivés ils ont intervenu il ya eu
les garçons sont passés en conseil de
discipline j'ai témoigné j'ai dû
expliquer j'ai expliqué là pourquoi je
crois que c'était là j'ai pas les sept
filles trou j'ai pas à protéger personne
j'y vois la bombe ont agressé
physiquement ils m'ont dit si ils m'ont
dit ça
voilà tu es une [ __ ] tu es une fille
était la veuve et la fille de green
commenté commencé dans ta culotte enfin
les choses comme ça quoi c'était très
violent donc ces enfants là on était
vraiment fonctionné fortement les
parents ont été convoqués
seas aller assez loin
[Musique]
entre marie et mathilde et caroline
sept-îles il y a plus de 30 ans de
différence
même si les mentalités ont évolué leur
mère marisa reste très vigilante sur
leur vie au collège
[Musique]
dans une semaine les deux soeurs font
leur rentrée dans un nouvel
établissement
aujourd'hui avec leur mère elles
repèrent le trajet
j'aimerais vous poser une question par
contre quoi est-ce que je vais vendre
directeur
pour leur parler d'eux
de la situation familiale ou la sq comme
je fais chaque année ou est-ce que vous
préférez vous débrouiller tout seul
je fais j'en parle oui toi tu débrouille
tout seul ouais mais les gamins qui vont
qui vont éventuellement deux précités en
me disant voix et hammerson wind to sata
petit matin vous vous en foutez moi et
m'a jamais vu leurs effectifs batwa le
caractère que tard c'est normal
une tigresse
notamment le
club oui et toi marie on a déjà fait des
réflexions oui estime que normalement
j'étais pas normal il était malade
des choses de ce genre
dupont allait rentrer je me rappelle ce
jour là elle est rentrée à la maison
complètement déboussolé en larmes elle
m'a dit maman tu vas bientôt mourir tu
es malade
sur coup j'ai souri puis après j'ai vu
que c'était vraiment du sérieux et à ce
moment là je me suis posé avec elle et
je lui ai demandé ce qui s'était passé à
l'école et elle m'a dit mais tu te rends
compte à l'école il ya des enfants qui
m'ont dit que si jamais tu avais des
enfants les aliments il leur manquerait
une jambe ou un bras que toi tu étais
malade que si que ça bon nous y sommes
aussi ouverts chouette on va pas rentrer
dedans
voilà les filles
dans quelques jours je vous l'aï fait
dans ce film
on emplacement naugrim pda la maison
pour désacraliser les termes ça permet
que si jamais elles entendent en cours
de récréation ouais t'es une fille de
guînes ou quoi que ce soit ça va passer
comme une lettre à la poste ils vont
simplement dit roy et alors je vois pas
où est le problème en fait même les
gamins entreprises emploient des termes
ils savent pas que ce sont deux ils
savent pas tout ce que c'est que ça peut
être une insulte le mobile entend
tellement partout pdk une bagarre sont
la première chose qu'on dise 61 qu'un
sale [ __ ] et puis ça donc pour eux le
mot [ __ ] [ __ ] ça représente des
insultes comme con
j'en dis les gentils d'autres c'est bien
je continuais de vulgaire c'est
formidable les bips
je pense pas que je pense pas qu'ils
aient vraiment ils disent green comme
dirait lesbiennes voilà sept consciente
que ça existe cette homophobie tout cas
moi je suis sûr que ça existe le commun
des fois il ya même eu des bagarres
entre les hommes les homophobes
c'est très violent
bah moi balance m'avait bien dit amer si
oui j'ai fait oui à la paix non c'était
juste pour dire non non mais c'est pas
ce qu'on m'a dit qu'il y avait une heure
après il a fermé sa gueule il a rien dit
ben si on m'insulte après je réplique
mais pas en mai pas violemment jeu
répliquant en parrain et en expliquant
en expliquant que je suis pas différente
parce que je suis comme tu comme lui
et s'y est dit et antoine ont bien
accepter l'homosexualité de leur père
jacques lors de son coming out quand ils
avaient 15 et 11 ans ils ont tué en
revanche de façon très différente de
l'assumer
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas eu de problèmes avec mes
amis chefs un jeu j'en ai parlé à mes
amis les plus proches assez vite et je
savais qu'il y avait pas de problème
quoi qui comprendrait très bien et j'ai
juste eu des petites règles sont étonnés
genre ah bon et on perd ils étaient
mariés avant et voilà enfin ouais c'est
légitime quoi c'est vrai qu'il a changé
de vie du coup il était un peu étonné
mais bon après voilà ben moi nous je les
gardais pour moi je lui en ai parlé à
personne justement parce que
je savais très bien que la réaction de
de mes copains ou deux mais des
connaissances que j'avais au collège
allait être si si je lui disais j'allais
forcément subir des insultes ou ou
vraiment beaucoup de chose de plaisant
parce que l'image je savais très bien
que l'image que les gens du collège
avait des homosexuels étaient négatives
c'était pas lourd ça de ne pas pouvoir
se confier et ben non non non c'était
s'était pas lourd ne pas pouvoir se
confier le plus lourd c'était le
quotidien c'est à dire on avait autre
chose à penser que l'homosexualité notre
notre père donc c'était pas du tout de
problème c'était une farce était même
pas je dirige du problème mais c'est pas
du tout la chose principale qui trottait
dans ma tête à ce moment là enfin voilà
en tant que collégiens en cours machin
truc ça ça stresse un peu donc
l'homosexualité de mon père on la zap
quoi pour inviter des copains la maison
tout simplement alors quand j'ai mené un
copain et que je jugeais qu'il n'était
pas digne d un pas dit que qui pouvaient
qu'il n'était pas capable d'entendre
quelques mon père est homosexuel je
disais que le copain de mon père s'il
est l âge et que c'était mon oncle comme
ça comme ça il n'y avait pas d'ambiguïté
aérien c'était mon cas on pensait tous
qui est des ombres peur d'avoir 100 donc
[Musique]
quant à clément et théo ils n'ont jamais
caché que leur mère était homo à leurs
copains et copines de collèges comme les
honore et mathilde
mais là encore chacun la joue à sa façon
moi je préférais le mettre à plat comme
j'ai déjà dit je préférais mettre à plat
tout de suite géré directement jeu des
parents homos donc si ça gêne quelqu'un
prévenez moi j'en parlerai pas où l'on
peut faire entre c'est pas un problème
par exemple ben les premières soirées
qu'on a fait que j'ai dû inviter des
amis chez moi
j'ai prévenu tout le monde et c'est à ce
moment là que tout le monde a été au
courant mais ça a été très vite réparé
sexuelles sont en
moi j'en ai aussi dit cela me suis
directement la couleur parce que ça je
n'ai pas eu l'impression mais non mais
c'est une course que j'ai l'ifm
salut je suis déjà
partenaires
dans le style qua non c'est non mais
c'est une logique commune trouve mais
effectivement on n'a pas du tout le même
mais il approche par rapport à sa juste
moi fait ramener enfin venue mais ça ne
l'est pas dans la conversation
effectivement après pas toujours le
petit moment où d'après monde justement
la différence c'est que moi j'appréhende
et jamais je n'appréhendais pas de dire
que j'avais départ ou non c'était
quelque chose que j'appréhende ai pas je
voulais te dire je voulais que les
autres soient au courant pourquoi cela
n'est pas d'objection à non absolu le
fait que tu moi j'en doute
préventivement si c'était une façon
d'apprendre mais je l'appréhendais pas
d'une façon d'intérieur consciente mais
je me disais pas j'ai peur
comment il a réagi et dont je me suis
jamais je me suis jamais posé cette
question moi je préfère lui dire au
moins c'est bon c'est fait puis ça me
fait quand même si inconscients ça me
soulage y est clément il attend que ça
arrivait par contre quand ça arrive ça
lui fait un petit coup de stress et
c'est un peu mal etc mais une fois que
ça
[Rires]
donc
dans la caméra
pour l'instant t au et jules vivent leur
situation familiale en toute insouciance
leurs parents karim et yann mène une vie
des plus simples dans l'ariège on s'est
rendu compte en étant visible en ne
faisant rien porté à nos enfants on
s'est construit en tant que famille et
puis c'est vrai que la visibilité le
naturel le fait de vivre au quotidien
d'aller chez femmes à faire des progrès
comme aujourd'hui de se balader au
marché avec nos enfants de de ne porter
aucun ne faire aucun aucun prosélytisme
mais aussi en même temps de rester
naturel faisait qu' on se glisse dans la
masse et que les gens globalement en
avait mais alors vraiment rien à faire
rien on sent rien du tout on sent pas
d'animosité on sent pas de stress
ne pas raser les murs assumer son
orientation sexuelle et son statut de
parents homos pour les couples que nous
avons rencontrés c'est une des clés pour
que leurs enfants vivent au mieux leurs
spécificités familiale
m
pourtant il leur reste un problème
toutes ces familles homoparentales comme
celle de marjolaine alice et leur fille
hasard conçu par don de sperme anonyme
en belgique ne sont pas reconnues par
l'état français
aux yeux de la loi asana qu'une mère
marjolaine la femme qui l'a porté
à l'iss elle n'existe pas
ado
une situation difficile à vivre au
quotidien que leurs copains hétéros sont
loin d'imaginer
[Musique]
par rapport à ça j'ai aucun statut légal
une personne par rapport à la loi je
suis une personne comme ça comme une
autre si jamais je suis avec elle et qui
lui arrive un accident par exemple
quelque chose je n'ai aucune aucun aucun
pouvoir de légal je prendrai une
décision urgente
par exemple s'il lui arrive quelque
chose qu'elle se retrouve au
commissariat que moi je ne peux pas
aller la chercher et c'est moi je ne
peux pas arriver au commissariat dire je
viens chercher ma fille le fait de me
dire que je peux me retrouver dans une
situation je serai démunis que je
pourrai pas les départs de problèmes
administratifs de ce type ça c'est une
inquiétude qui est toujours un peu dans
un coin de ma tête même à l'école
si à l'école les joueurs n'étaient pas
complaisants alice enfin là ils nous ont
pas demandé mais l'année dernière nous
avait demandé une lettre
et m'ont demandé une laisse
enfin mode autorisation pour qualifier
de chercher à zahlé passe quand même
ce qui fait mal au coeur quoi quand même
enfin sous quel régime toutes deux
les enfants c'est que financier
[Musique]
par exemple si c'est pas souhaitable et
s'il t'arrive quelque chose à toi
quelque chose de grave'
si je meurs
à nice n'a aucun droit sur hazard c'est
au bon vouloir de ma famille tout ce que
ma famille décide peut l'entendre ce qui
est mieux alors on s'est quand même
prémunit donc mes parents ont dit qu
évidemment c c alice qui se vit près
dasa mais voilà on sait jamais ce qui se
passe aussi à ce moment-là ça remue
plein de choses on peut pas il vaudrait
mieux que ce soit la loi qui ait statué
que ce serait tellement plus simple plus
claire et plus rassurant donc ça veut
dire quoi que hazard finalement elle
n'est pas comme les autres enfants
qui étaient pas comme les autres enfants
mais est comme les autres enfants c'est
juste que tu es deux mamans elles
peuvent pas être reconnus de la même
manière par la loi par tous les autres
gens s'y met
[Musique]
ça par rapport aux autres enfants sont
là tout autour de nous elle n'a pas les
mêmes le même groupe les autres elle n'a
pas de faire la bise
enfin la famille n'est pas en collant
comme tel
les enfants de familles homoparentales
des enfants de seconde zone
photo
yann étant le père biologique de théo et
de jules conçu par mère porteuse à
l'étranger dans leur famille c'est karim
qui n'est pas reconnu par la république
française
alors dans l'espoir que leur fils est un
jour le droit d'avoir deux parents
légaux comme tous les enfants de france
le couple vote aujourd'hui aux primaires
socialistes
[Musique]
et
on se déplace en famille pour voter
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya des
revendications importantes qui vont être
prises en compte au cours dé
présidentielle en mai 2012 dont le
mariage homosexuel et l'adoption donc
voilà on veut faire entendre notre voix
ça c'est arnault
sas et martin
qu'est-ce que tu choisirais ségolène
françois manuel jean-michel martinez
arnaud
celui-là
important de voter
parce que les gens ils d hippolyte ici
il ya des lois qui autorisent qui
interdit certaines choses et parfois on
a le pouvoir de les changer alors quand
on veut l'échanger il faut se déplacer
pour voter nous les papas on voudrait
pouvoir se marier parce qu'on trouve que
c'est très important que notre amour il
soit reconnu que notre famille soit
pleinement reconnue donc on vient voter
tu comprendre que vous parle c'est trop
compliqué et trop compliqué encore
d'accord tu veux que les papas et
puissent se marier faire une grande fête
eh bah voila tu as tout compris il faut
voter
sans que la la société la société a
vraiment bien évolué les hommes
politiques n'évoluera ils ne comprennent
pas ils ne suivent pas les évolutions de
la société des nouvelles familles
aujourd'hui 63 % des français sont
favorables au mariage de couples
homosexuels
et 58 % accepteraient qu'ils adoptent
voilà
[Musique]
une évolution des mentalités déjà
entériné par plusieurs états européens
aussi différents que la norvège
l'angleterre ou l'espagne
il y a deux ans même un pays de
tradition catholique comme le portugal
autorisait les homosexuels à se marier
[Musique]
et
m
je
[Musique]